Dahmer series man it's on Netflix
got a lot of feelings about it the first
30 minutes
is some of the creepiest television
I've ever watched in my life you get a
visceral reaction from yourself when you
watch this Dahmer was like
otherworldly psycho just the fact that
he was so brazen and just completely
psycho and out of it
can you imagine I have neighbors just
imagine like you hearing muffled screens
or you hear him saw you're hearing you
know power tools
and just like it really made me feel
uncomfortable and at first I was like
Ugh this series but at the same time I
think
that's the point of it the point of it
is to make you feel uncomfortable and
really think like yo there are horrible
people out here like this so those are
the things I say I like about the series
but I'll say this man
why make this
like at a certain point you go
why do we need to still
use this for entertainment are they
going to make like are we going to say
you know Hitler the young years I mean
that Series going to come to CBS there's
a reason why you don't see a lot of
Hitler movies it's because it was so
horrible it's like nah maybe we don't
make money off this